you know in my head I take a very Hapa
approach to this I think that you know
if you want to have a Libertarian
Society you can have no tolerance
tolerance at all in your libertarian
Society for communism I believe what
does that mean yeah Hans Hermann Hapa is
a oh yeah he's a he's a writer who talks
a lot about Liberty just like no
communist celeb yeah I mean you can't
you know he takes a little further than
that but yeah he says that you know in a
uh libertarian Society you cannot you
cannot suffer the Communists they have
to be physically removed like not even a
Communist party not at all because in
Canada they have a Communist party but
they have the kids
my view has been uh I would say maybe
like six years ago my view was I believe
in free speech even if you're a
communist or a fascist or whatever we
must defend Free Speech now my position
is if you believe in free speech then I
will defend your free speech if you
don't believe people should have free
speech then I will defend your request
to not have free speech and not help you
when you get silent